[موسيقى]
في صيف عام
1988 ومعه الاف السجناء السياسيين ولم
تتحقق العداله لهذه الاعدامات ولم نعلم
حتى الان لماذا تم اعدامهم واقصده هنا من
خلال القنوات الرسميه ولم نجد جثته واين
دفن ما زالت هناك كثير من الاسئله حول هذه
المجزره
[موسيقى]
قبل انتهاء الحرب مع العراق او ما تسمى
بشرب قلاع السم اي قبل ايقاف اطلاق النار
اصدر الخميني فتوى وقبل شهور عده من مجزره
صيف
1988 تم فصل السجناء واخرون نقلوهم من سجن
الى اخر حيث كانوا يتهياون للاعدامات وهذا
ما اطلق عليه لجان الموت وكان من ضمن
اللجان ابراهيم رئيسي والاشخاص الذين
شاركوا اصبحت لهم مناصبوا في النظام حتى
ان رئيسي اصبح انذاك وزيرا للعداله
[موسيقى]
في المره الاولى التي اعتقلوا فيها شقيقي
لم يكن لديهم اي شيء ضده لذلك اطلقوا
صراحه في المره الثانيه اعتقلوه ونقلوه
الى سجن سري خاص للتعذيب
وعندما
ذهبت امي واختي لرؤيته اصبح شعره الاسود
ابيض بالكامل وفقد كل اسنانه بسبب التعذيب
[موسيقى]